demi lovato rings in her 27th birthday
with a little help from ariana grande
this is really exciting for me
the singer celebrated her special day by
heading out to our ease concert in
London and get ready to feel some
serious feelgood's because Ari and her
dancers welcomed Demi in the sweetest
way before the show kicked off how cute
is that hug heart exploding Demi shared
this video on Instagram writing
alongside it quote this was too sweet
not to post before show prayer they did
this for my bday I'm so so proud of you
ariana grande you've been killed that I
love you tons later Ari shared a
screenshot of Debbie's post to her insta
story adding I love you happy birthday
in an hour during the show Demi was
instagramming a lot sharing clips of
ariana bringing the house down and
writing things like Yas Queen and my
girl I mean and WTF re you Queen
at one point Debbie got up close and
personal to the stage and fangirled just
like the rest of us
[Music]
and she danced so hard she even took her
shoes off at one point later Demi shared
a video taken by her Inari's manager
Scooter Braun showing her blowing out
the candles on her birthday cake and yep
re was there too
[Applause]
Demi captioned the clip quote they
literally filmed saying happy birthday
twice and Scooter Braun still forgot to
press record
adding ariana grande's face is
everything and this video is a perfect
glimpse of how [ __ ] happy and rad my
birthday is this year so so happy and I
love my new family
thank you guys love you scooter shared
the same video to his own Instagram and
poked fun at his big fail in the caption
naturally re commented on the post
writing
we literally sang it twice so he could
start over and this is what he got it
has been a big year for Demi July 24th
marked exactly one year since she was
hospitalized for a drug overdose and a
source previously told et she's quote in
a really good place right now and just
celebrated 365 days of sobriety it's my
birthday I'm so happy I literally never
woken up this happy before in my life
happy birthday Demi here's to nothing
but more of the good stuff of course
we'll be right here to keep you up to
date on all things Demi Lovato so make
sure to keep it locked right here on et
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye
for now
[Music]